how useful are personality tests in your
opinion ah that is a great question so
we've just run a really big study on
this that I'm super excited about in
fact this is the first time I'm ever
talking about it so hot off the process
um so the most popular personality test
in the world seems to be the Myers braks
test but the Myers braks test also
called the mbti is a commercial test
right so it's hard to study because it's
you know it's owned by a company and so
on so what we did is we took the public
information about the constructs that
have been you know known about what it's
trying to measure and we designed our
own test designed to measure those same
constructs I'll just call a yian test
because it's you know it's not exactly
precisely the same as the commercial one
but it's designed to measure similar
ideas and then we actually put it to the
test and so way the way that we did this
is we also developed uh what's called a
big five test are you familiar with the
Big Five personality model yes so these
are so it's interesting because the Big
Five personality model is the one used
by academics it's the one they call the
gold standard whereas the Myers Briggs
is is the one that's like super popular
for the lay people and often you know
academics kind of pooo it and say ah
it's not so great right and so so we
wanted to put them against each other
and so the way we did this is we took a
whole bunch of facts about a person's
life it was about 42 different facts so
everything from how satisfied they are
with their life to how many friends they
have you know to things like you know
have they been arrested and so on and
then we had them take both of these
tests our big five test gold standard
academic one and uh and this Yan test
designed after Myers Briggs and said
well how well can each test predict
what's true about people's lives as a
measure of how good they are so do you
want to guess what happened when we did
this and I'll just before I have you
guess I'll just throw in one third thing
we also used astrological Sun Signs as a
control group so we took people you know
zodiac sign are you a Pisces or an Aries
or whatever and that was our kind of
control so we tried to predict things
about your life using that uh using this
young idea and then using the big five
why did you need need the astrology
thing oh it's a good way to calibrate uh
the statistics of our system to see if
we yeah if uh if whether we can predict
with astrology right right okay uh I
would
guess
that Mayers Briggs performed probably
quite poorly I'd guess that the big five
was more accurate probably moderately
accurate i' guess maybe it captures
like let's say maybe between 30 and 50%
of the outcomes that someone gets and
then Myers Briggs is is less but I don't
know how much less okay there's a great
guess so I'll start with our control
group The the Zodiac signs astrology so
had 0% predictive accuracy all 42
outcomes so you literally able to
predict nothing about people now okay I
that's sort of what I expected but I
wanted to be fair and really give it a
tough so we ran exactly the same
procedure okay um then we look at the
youngest and that predicted so the way
we measure this it's a measure called R
it was about 0.14 so basically you can
think about that is it's a bit
correlated with these outcomes so 0.14
correlation to the outcomes when you
when you use that um uh sorry so
slightly worse than that sorry it's 0.11
so about 0.11 so a little bit correl the
outcomes the big five was twice as good
so it's 0.22 and this leads to a really
funny thing which is that Myers Brigg's
ideas in our test was exactly halfway
between astrology and the big five so
that's kind of a fun
Takei why do you think it's the case
that Myers Briggs is so much less
accurate than the big five well we studi
this uh quite extensively so the first
thought we had is maybe it's because the
Myers Briggs has four factors that it's
measuring right so there's the E versus
the I the N versus the S and so on
whereas the big five has five factors so
maybe that's giving the Big Five in
Advantage now to be fair we designed
both tests have the same number of
questions so it wasn't the number of
questions that was making the difference
so then we could say well what if we get
rid of the fifth factor of the big five
the fifth Factor being neuroticism which
is which is the big five factor in
personality that's least related to
Myers Briggs and when we did that um it
did hurt the accuracy of the big five it
fell from about 0. 22 correlation to
about 0.14 but it's still beat the Myers
Briggs which is pretty wild so e so that
wasn't the full explanation um even the
four four factors of the Myers Briggs um
just seem to just not be doing as good a
job as those four other factors of the
big five there's also another thing that
really hurts the Myers breaks so I said
that had about um a 0.11 correlation
predicting these 42 outcomes right well
that's actually being a little generous
to the my Myers Briggs kind of test
because very often when they're
presented they're done as dichotomies
right they don't give you a score on
every trait they say you're an i or an e
you're an N versus S this is typically
how people use the the test you and say
I'm an entj right that actually hurts
the accuracy even more and the reason is
because most personality traits fall on
a bell curve right if you you know you
imagine the shape of a bell there are
lots lots of people near the middle of a
trait and there are fewer as you get
further away from the center the problem
is if you dichotomize these traits
you're essentially cutting them down the
middle imagine cutting a bell down the
middle and anyone who just happens to be
the left side you you call an eye and I
the right you're lumping you're lumping
an awful lot of people some that are
moderate some that are quite extreme and
some that are very extreme all in
together precisely precisely and there's
a whole bunch of people right near the
margin so if they maybe if it you know
if they had their coffee 10 minutes
earlier today they might have answered
one question differently and flipped
from an eye to a knee um so they for
that reason these kinds of tests T to be
unstable and so that actually um when
you take it that into account it
actually hurt the accuracy even more it
falls from 0.11 correlation to 0.08
um my people all of the people who've
got their Myers Briggs personality type
in their bios on instam stagram and
Twitter are halfway between a legitimate
personality test and just saying
Pisces I would say in a way but I do
wanna I do want to steal man the the
point of view that says that that the
Myers brick sty tests are actually a
good test and the the thing that I think
is actually really useful about them is
that they help provide a language that a
lot of people use to communicate things
about themselves and communicate things
about each other right um so I'm an entj
according to mybriggs and if you tell
someone that it can communicate a lot of
information very quickly and so it
provides a kind of shorthand language
it's also not totally useless like it's
not it doesn't have zero predictive
accuracy right has some so I you know I
don't want to discredit I think it does
actually help people understand
themselves and each other I just think
we could do even better if we use more
more accurate tests um so you know if
you think in terms of the big five which
has five factors it's got this soon as
the acronym ocean is used so you've got
o for openness which is like openness to
experiments openness to ideas being
imaginative things like that you've got
C conscientiousness being like organized
and disciplined things like that um you
got the E for extraversion which is
actually very similar to the meersburg
extraversion uh you got a for
agreeableness which is being
compassionate and polite and then n for
neuroticism which is experiencing
intense emotions anxiety depression
things like
that would you ever consider doing
hexico that's a great question so some
people have argued in favor of the
hexico model which basically adds a six
factor to the big five and the the basic
argument goes that if so actually let me
just step back and say how is the big
five invented at all like why are we
where did the big five come from so the
basic idea is they took all the
different ways you could describe
someone in English language so all these
different adjectives and they they said
to people for each of these adjectives
say which apply to yourself and say
which don't and then once they collected
all this data they did a statistical
analysis and what they were looking for
is certain adjectives if you say it
applies to you there are other
adjectives it also probably implies will
apply to you too so if you say that
you're organized you also probably will
say that you're you know rule bang or
something like that right if you say
that you're social you also probably say
that you're talkative and so what they
found just purely statistically this was
is not Theory driven it was actually
empirically driven they found these five
clusters of traits right that's where
the ocean model comes from O C A an each
is a cluster of traits that they cluster
together and then people also replicated
this work by instead of having people
describe themselves they had people
describe each other and so they they
seem to get similar results now some
psychologists have argued that you need
to add a six Factor um that if you do
the factor analysis in some settings you
get the six one and they call it the h
factor and it stands for honesty
humility and so it's things like you
know are you do you lie do you
manipulate people do you brag are you
arrogant things like that it's sort of
like the evilness factor to some extent
um this is a debate that's raged back
and forth in the psychological Community
about like to what extent is it really
there why is it not always found
reliable I mean we did one test this was
a very preliminary test where we just
Tred to see if we could get better
predictive AC accuracy using hexico in
the big five and we didn't see much
Advantage so we generally just don't use
it in our models because we just didn't
see enough enough reason to add it you
know if you're going to add an six
Factor you want to really be driving
outcomes yeah I like hexico I learned
about honesty humility on an episode
maybe six months ago about bullying
actually really awesome episode about
bullying and um it was the first time
that anybody had ever folded in the
honesty humility element of it uh and it
really does make sense it certainly
feels like a uh a Dynam
like an area of territory that um isn't
fully covered that would also be
important but then I mean you know I can
just somebody else that has a different
value set to me might say that oh well I
think that this your opinion on ice
cream is really important or something
else right like it's just me feeling out
some idea about what I think matters uh
but yeah the the other explanation that
I've heard for or the justification for
hexico is that it aligns with
evolutionary explanations more
accurately that it is able to be you can
use adaptive explanations for Behavior
more effectively when you're using
hexico than when you're using the big
five um but yeah I I think that you're
really
right the Myers Briggs I'm mean intj I
don't even remember what any of those
stand for or what that really means but
by making discrete buckets of this um it
does cause people who are only am I a
moderate inj am I an extreme in am I a
capital I lowercase n like what's the
proportion of this but as you said it
allows you very very quickly to
communicate an awful lot of information
about your personality and even if it's
only you know a little bit correlated
that's more than saying okay so what
percentile politeness are you and what
percentile agreeableness what percentile
are you because that's like you how am I
supposed to put all of this together so
I suppose yeah this there's trade-offs
accuracy for brevity uh is a trade-off
really that you're making between Big
Five and Myers Briggs
exactly and so we actually also looked
at why people like the Myers break so we
included this in one of the studies we
ran and we found this fascinating thing
we showed people their youngi report at
the end of taking our study and we also
showed them their big five report and
they felt that they were about equally
accurate so that that was fascinating to
us because we know that we actually have
more predictive power with the Big Five
results but people didn't perceive it as
more accurate we also found a re a
really fascinating thing which is that
we asked people how good did it make you
feel and people found that the the yian
report made them feel better than the
big five report and this makes sense if
you start thinking about what the big
five says it says hey buddy you're
disagreeable and neurotic and closed
right and it's like oh yeah that's s
kind of makes you sound like and
whereas if you look at you know Myers
breaks test what are they telling you
they're they're not telling you you're
bad they're never telling you you're bad
you're saying you're either thinking or
feeling those both sound like great
things right um but if you think about
the thinking feeling tradeoff well in
Big Five the closest thing is actually
agreeableness and it's telling you
you're agreeable or disagreeable right
neither of those things sound good yeah
neither of them sound good and if you
think about the the sort of the kind of
Meer brig's approach with thinking
feeling what it's saying is that oh no
it's not that you're either like a
compassionate person feeling or you're a
jerk right it's that you're either a
compassionate person or you're logic
based right that sounds way better right
you're not a jerk you're just using much
better branding from Myers's Briggs for
all of the different types yeah
and it gives you a nice language that
the big five has struggled to give you
that language that really concisely to
say I'm a blank blank blank and people
are like oh yeah I got it you also did
some big studies on habit setting
recently obviously something that a lot
of people are very obsessive over Atomic
Habits by James Clear one of the
bestselling non-fiction books maybe ever
but certainly of the last five years
probably the bestselling non-fiction
book over the last five years except for
maybe some autobiographies what did you
learn from this big study yeah so this
was really exciting we actually ran two
really big studies the first was was
actually kind of a Bonker study we said
we don't know what actually really works
in the real world to help people form
habits so we're going to test 22 things
simultaneously and so the design of the
study is we recruited a large number of
people is like something like 500 people
and we randomize them so each person got
five habit techniques picked from a set
of 22 that we implemented and then that
what that meant is at the end of the
study we could then analyze the
relationship between which of these 22
techniques someone was randomized to get
and how they formed their habit did they
succeeded It ultimately and there were
some really interesting findings so this
was our first study and then later we
went to confirm it but to the first
study some interesting findings first of
all many of these techniques did not
work at all which is really fasinating
to see in fact the vast majority of them
completely bombed right so that's the
first take away human behavior change is
hard that's fundamentally difficult lots
of people want to go tell you that they
have the the one you know quick life
hack to change your behavior uh no not
really sorry unfortunately that doesn't
work that way um the second thing that
we found that was really interesting is
that motivation was mattered a great
deal there was there was one of the
strongest predictive factors of whether
someone succeeded their habit was just
how motivated they were at the beginning
this is kind of an obvious thing but it
actually really speaks to this idea that
if you're going to try to form a new
habit try to pick one you feel really
motivated to do like don't pick the one
that you just like are Force feeding
yourself pick the one that you're really
excited about um because you actually
probably will have a better chance of
success so obvious but but useful
Insight um okay so then what actually
worked in this pilot study right um we
found five things that actually seem to
be promising um I'll tell you about I'll
just tell you about a couple of them
just so you know so I don't give you a
long list but the first that I thought
was really interesting is this technique
we call habit reflection um and the way
that that works is you look back at a
previous habit you've succeeded at and
you write down it's important to write
this down what did you do that helped
you succeed with that previous habit you
know did you try to do at the same time
every day did you you tell your friends
that you wanted to do this habit or
whatever whatever it is that you did
that you think helped you succeed then
you do the Second Step which is you
write down how you can apply those
lessons to this new
habit and so what's really cool about
this habit reflection technique it only
takes a few minutes but it's sort of
self- customizing it's really an
introspection exercise to figure out
what works for you based on your own
past results yes so in a way it's sort
of Dumb and obvious but it's like who
would have ever thought to do this until
it popped out it's like the uh it's like
the machine extrapolated valtion for the
for the alignment problem in uh like AGI
that you're using you to split test all
of the different ideas and then once
you've come up with a winner you refer
back to you to sort the current problem
absolutely and you know it reminds me
also of like some of the work of Daniel
Conan and how do you um how do you get
around things like the planning fallacy
where you know people will say oh I'll
get this project done two months and
it'll take six months right and he's
like okay go think back to past cases
like how long did it actually take you
in real situations that you were in that
were similar it's like go back to your
past habit analyze it what actually
worked what didn't work right so simple
but but uh potentially very useful um
another one I want to mention and this
one takes a little bit of a preamble so
one of the ideas I think is really
powerful in habit formation is this idea
of triggers um and so on my podcast was
called the clear Thinking podcast I had
an expert of a habits and he had this
really nice acronym when you think about
habits you can think about the different
triggers those habits so his name is Jim
Davies and he calls it the Habit acronym
h b t very convenient so the first is
that your your habits can be triggered
by the humans around you that's the H
they can be triggered by the activity
you're doing that's the a they can be
triggered by your bearing which is where
you are like are you at your home or
your office uh then there's the I that
you can be triggered by your internal
State like how if you're hungry or not
for example and finally T the time of
day right and so for our study we were
thinking about well is there some way to
bring triggers into your habit that's
super simple dead easy anyone can do it
and so we came up with this ridiculously
stupid method we call home reminders you
just write notes to yourself and you
place them around your home of like when
this happens do this or here's the Habit
I'm GNA do every day and yeah that was
another one out of the 22 that was one
of the best performing strange as stupid
as it is so I I love incredibly stupid
simple things that actually seem to work
so I had laser eye surgery about 3 weeks
ago now and there is
a protocol of eye drops that you need to
keep uh doing to keep the Eye Health
good and whatever uh and these eye drops
come in little droppers maybe sort of
two m 3 mil droppers and it's such a
good idea because I've got them
everywhere they are all over my house
which means I'm sat at my desk it's like
ah it's probably been about two hours
since I put eye drops I'm going to go to
the bathroom like I'll I'll take one of
the the droppers with me and or I'll
I'll make sure that I do that or they're
next to my bathroom upstairs in my
bedroom or they're you know wherever
like they're in my gym bag everywhere
and um that's kind of like a a physical
version of the poit note I suppose what
are the other three run us run us
through all five people want to know the
the big one is yeah yeah sure um Okay so
we've got habit reflection home
reminders is the ones we talked about
the next one is mini habits and this
will be familiar to people that have
read um James clear's book uh the idea
is you take the Habit that you want to
form let's say you want to like you're
like okay I want to do my like full
workout routine every morning you design
a tiny version of this that is so fast
and simple that you never have an excuse
not to do it and then basically you set
a rule that if you do not have time or
effort or motivation whatever to do the
full version you at least have to do the
Mini version right um so so your mini
version might be okay do 10 push-ups you
never have an excuse not to do 10
push-ups you know if you well assuming
you can do 10 pushups um but uh but you
may have a you know maybe you have a
legitimate excuse not to go to the gym
for 40 minutes right right and then
what's the reason why why is that so
effective at keeping the habit going why
don't people just tumble into only doing
10 push-ups and never going to the gym
yeah it's a good question because you
could worry okay maybe I'm just going to
every day do 10 push-ups instead um but
I think my my theory is that the bigger
problem is not that you start the habit
and you don't you know you don't do the
full thing it's that you actually just
don't do the Habit right so it's like
it's just establishing The Habit is more
important than doing the full habit um
because it's a bigger failure mode so
the key is never miss a day even means
you just did 10 push-ups because at
least the 10 push-ups then is an
opportunity to remind yourself oh my
goal is actually go to the gym right
whereas the bigger problem is four weeks
from now you're just like not even
thinking about going to gym at all uh
how much of this do you think is the
story that we tell ourselves about
momentum and consistency and like shame
and guilt and and self-doubt around
whether or not we can achieve
things yeah it's a good question um I
think there's this powerful idea that
success is motivating for further
success and so let's say that every day
you only do 10 push-ups when you meant
to go do you know 40 minutes of the gym
you might actually feel bad about that
you might actually feel like you failed
and um but that's just framing thing
right it's just like well that you
decided that's a failure uh what I would
actually encourag is the opposite to say
until you've established yes if every
single day you're doing 10 push-ups now
it's time to set the by bar you know
higher and say okay can I go to the gym
for 40 minutes but until you are doing
temps every single day without fail if
you do you should feel good about that
you're like yes oh no I I I was saying
that the reason I think this does work
is that if you don't have even anything
that is the microcosm version of the
proper habit then you are generally a
piece of right like I didn't go to
the gym at all I didn't even do one
pushup I just laid in bed uh I think
that it helps to avoid the downward
spiral of that pattern recognition oh
I'm the sort of person that doesn't go
to the gym I'm exactly the sort of
person that wouldn't do the this thing
and before you know it James talks so
much about like identity-based habit
change which I guess may be one of the
remaining two or maybe not um but this
works with identity based habit change
like if you are the sort of person who
goes to the gym for 40 minutes on
average two or three times a week and on
the days that you don't you're the sort
of person that makes sure that they do
10 push-ups at home I think you can
probably say that yeah I'm like a
physically disciplined person and I do
when I say I'm going to do a thing I do
a thing and kind of like the Myers
Briggs being quite binary this also
reduces down the binary nature it Al
almost gives you uh a spectrum of of
habits to go on right you're not just I
either did The Habit going to the gym
which was a one or zero I didn't go
there's like oh there's like a there's
like a 50th percentile here which is I
did 10 pushups absolutely yeah it gives
you a finer grain reward system you
don't have to doesn't have to be
complete success or complete fail
failure right um and I think I think
this kind of idea is especially
important for people that are really
struggling like if you're struggling
with really severe depression really
severe anxiety maybe just a little thing
is all you can manage right now and that
could be a huge success for you so you
don't need to set your goal really high
and then feel like you're failing like
set your goal at something achievable
you should be able to do it with high
rate of success and then go do it and
now you're like okay well maybe I'm not
working out 40 minutes a day but I'm
doing 10 push-ups a day and that's
something to feel good about and then
they're like now you can bootstrap on
top of that so all right okay number
four again we love super simple stupid
things but the key is do they work
because most of them don't that's so the
the next one is um we us just call it
support of a friend and so here the idea
is think of someone in your life who
would actually be helpful at supporting
your habit and go tell them about it and
ideally suggest a way that they can
support your habit so this is going to
vary from person to person you know
sometimes they might be a partner who
can help motivate you or maybe they have
a habit and they can remind you to do it
with them every day uh maybe it'll be a
friend who can check in periodically
maybe yeah maybe it'll be a buddy you're
going to go to the gym with right so
there's a lot of different ways this can
operate but basically involving another
person who's going to play support for
you and of course it's up to you who is
supportive and who's going to demotivate
you right um and that brings us to the
final one which is again super super
simple which is uh we call listing habit
benefits you simply we this right at the
beginning when you're forming your habit
you just make a list of all the reasons
that this is a thing you want to do and
all the it's going to give you and it's
just trying to give you you know going
back to motivation and how key that was
to people succeeding and how predictive
it was you're trying to do is bootstrap
that motivation once you've decided this
is the thing I'm going to try to do you
want to get your motivation level as
high as you can and you can also review
that benefit list from time to time to
help like you know respond that
motivation if it's flagging out of the
original 22 techniques which were the
ones that worked the absolute worst were
there any that had a negative impact on
habit setting or were there any that
were just like this is completely
pointless oh that's a that's a great
question um well I'll tell you the most
shocking one that didn't work which is
in the uh academic literature there's
this technique um called whoop um it's
like wish uh outcome obstacle plan I
think it stands for and the idea it's
it's this idea that there been long
established in academic literature that
um basically what you do is you think
about this goal that you're going to um
try to achieve and then you think about
the outcomes if you do successfully
achieve it but then you think about the
obstacles in the way to achieving it and
then finally you come up with a plan
like when this obstacle comes up I'm G
to do this um when that obstacle comes
up and do that it's very it makes sense
intuitively that it would work we
thought it was going to work um we even
powered our study specifically to test
it because we just thought okay this is
a nice like standard intervention that
we can compare us against and we didn't
get any results for it so I don't
necessarily want to blame it on that
technique like you know it's always
possible it was a fluke or we didn't
implement it right in some way but I was
like shocked that this did not do
anything wow that is interesting I think
I'm pretty sure I've written down in
previous journals when I've been wanting
to do oh here's a contingency and this
is what I will overcome and so on and so
forth uh yeah I suppose now don't don't
stop using it if it works for you but
you know look at the academic literature
see what you know come to your
conclusion the consensus on it yeah yeah
I think most people will
you know combine a bunch of these
together for habits right and this is
the problem that you're not doing a
univariate analysis on exactly what
contributed to your habit sticking or
not sticking maybe you had a fruit bowl
that you bought that's now out oh well
that's kind of like one of your visual
triggers it's like a Post-It note that's
kind of lying around and then maybe
there was some other thing so there's
just a lot of different elements that
always contribute to this and they're
very rarely going to be done in in
isolation which is exactly why we needed
you to do your study yeah so we were
trying to figure this out and then but
here's the problem with our original
study design we tested so many things
that you could very reasonably say well
but maybe they were false positives
maybe it was flukes Etc and so we wanted
to really try to confirm this so what we
did is we took these five best
interventions um that I mentioned
already we packaged them to one tool and
it's completely free you can use it
right now if you want it's called daily
ritual and it's on our website clearth
thinking. org so you can go use it help
you form a new habit and we tested that
in a randomized control trial so this
was a new study designed to test that
tool and very happily it actually
succeeded in helping people stick to
their habit more compared to the control
group and so we track their habits over
eight weeks and those who use the daily
ritual tool um stuck to them at a more
reliable rate so that was really
satisfying to see hell yeah and so
that's a stack of these on top of each
other yeah because you know it's
interesting in real life any one thing
is probably not going to have like an
absolutely profound impact occasionally
it does but usually it's more additive
and so our goal once we had this initial
like we've got five promising things
let's just make the stack that is most
promising and it's even possible that
one or two of those doesn't do anything
but we're like with the stack the stack
works you know we're not can't be 100%
sure every ingredient is helpful yeah I
love it what about Valu ISM this is your
personal philosophy that I have never
heard of before but I think you've had
some personal success with what is Valu
ISM yeah so you haven't heard of it
because I invented it so but I invented
it but on the other hand like you there
are many elements of it that have been
inspired by lots of other things I'll to
say that but um so let me start by
talking about values because I think
that's sort of the core layer of this
and I will say Valu ism is my personal
life philosophy I've written a series of
essays about it if you want to read
those um it I have found it to be a very
fruitful life philosophy and it's my
attempt to really answer the question
what should you do with your life
especially if you don't have some big
belief system that you belong to like
okay maybe if you are a Catholic and you
believe all the Catholic ideas then like
maybe that gives you a structure of like
how to live your life I'm not a Catholic
you know I don't have I don't have that
overarching guiding structure so I'm
like what should I do with my life how
should I spend my time you know so this
is my time to answer that question so
starting with values I like to think of
values as being differenti into two
types there's intrinsic values and
instrumental values so intrinsic values
are the things we value for their own
sake we value them not just as a means
to an end but we value them
fundamentally right so an example of
this is being happy like if you're like
oh I did this thing it made me really
happy and someone like well why do you
care why would you care about being
happy you'd be like I just I just value
it right like there's nothing really
deeper than that you just want to be
happy right um whereas instrumental
values are things that we value merely
because they get us other things the
classic example is money imagine you
were on a a deserted island you had tons
of money but it didn't burn you couldn't
make fires with it you can't spend it on
anything it's not even worm enough to
you make a blanket out of it right it
would be totally useless right so money
is you know cash literally dollars um
have no intrinsic value they have lots
of instrumental value you can use them
to buy lots of things you can give them
the away to help the world Etc but
they're not intrinsically valuable and
the reason that I draw this distinction
is because a lot of people waste a lot
of time going after things they
instrumentally value and they forget
that they don't actually intrinsically
value these things so they forget that
they're means to an end they you know
and they treat them like the end in
itself and I think you know many of us
have seen this happen with money for
example where someone seems to be
mindlessly pursuing money way past the
point where it's even causing any
positive benefit for that it's just sort
of like they attach to the idea of just
making the number go up um so okay so
that's of the first base is we think
about instrumental values and intrinsic
values I'll stop there and see if you
had any questions about that and then at
all sense okay cool cool okay so then
what is value ISM it's a very simple
life philosophy it says basically two
steps one first work to figure out what
you intrinsically value separate that
out from what you instrumentally value
and then once you've done that step two
try to use effective methods to create
what you intrinsically value that's it
that's the whole life philosophy and you
might say well why what's the point why
would you go work out your inic values
and then try to use effective methods to
to create the things you inic value well
it's like because that is the things you
deeply value that's actually what your
brain like psychologically finds
valuable so like go do that thing and
when I say it that way it sounds
incredibly stupid and obvious it's like
well duh but here's the really crazy
thing as stupid and obvious as it seems
very few people live by this life
philosophy and often what I've told
people about they're like oh that makes
so much sense that's like crystallizing
this thing that I had in the back of my
mind that I like didn't have a precise
way of stating right so that's what I'm
trying to do is like crystallize this
idea and turn it into like a specific
life philosophy even though lots of
people might be like hovering around
this idea but just not have ever like
thought about it in that precise way
what are some of the potential pitfalls
when someone is taking inventory of the
intrinsic values yeah good question um
so the the first Pitfall is that people
often confuse them with their
instrumental values and um we actually
we spent a lot of time researching this
for so again for our website clearer
thinking. org we developed this thing
called the intrinsic values test you can
go on there it's free it will help you
figure out what your intrinsic values
are and when we first designed this test
we ran a study and we put people through
a little uh a little thing asking them
about their intrinsic values is this
intrinsic value is that intrinsic value
and we found that tons of people even
though we had like defined intrinsic
value for them they put instrumental
values instead right they put things
that are like oh getting a car or like
getting money or uh you know having you
know healthy food and it's like no no no
those are not and so what we realized is
like oh no we actually have to teach
people in the tool how to separate these
out and it's like a pretty complex
process so we have to ended up as part
of the tool the first thing you go
through is a little mini training module
that teaches you how to separate them
and actually gives you examples and like
quizzes you and then gives you the test
so it helps you really kind of clarify
so that's like the number one first
challenge um
uh so uh in addition to that I think um
another challenge with the with
intrinsic values is that they often come
in conflict with each other so um an
example that has come up with me before
is I could be honest with a friend but I
know it would hurt their feelings right
and one of my deep intrinsic values is
being honest it's um it's telling the
truth but another deep intrinsic value
of mine is not causing suffering and
especially not causing suffering for
people I care about and so I think when
we actually try to use this in practice
we very quickly will realize that these
situations arise where intrinsic values
are in conflict and then we have to
start navigating them and so so in my my
kind of sequence of essays about Valu
ISM that's like the second essay is like
what do you do when your inic values
conflict with each other yeah what do
you do ah so what I find really helpful
is restating the tradeoff in terms of
your intrinsic values so you start with
this complicated and like this is
something I actually have done with
friends many times and found really
useful like a friend will come with a
problem there struggling with I'll I'll
listen to their problem and I'll say hey
it sounds to me like you've got these
values X and Y and then if you do the
first option you get a bunch of X but
you sacrifice Y and if you do the second
option you get a bunch of Y be
sacrificed and they're like oh my God
yes this is exactly what's happening so
that's my first step is really try to
rewrite the problem in terms of like the
intrinsic values on either side of the
the choices and then once you've done
that sometimes you're lucky and you'll
realize oh like one side's a clear
winner in terms of my values it was
maybe a difficult it maybe it felt like
a difficult decision because maybe one
of the sides of the choice was painful
or stressful or whatever but when you
put in terms of values it's just really
clear one's the winner and if you don't
do that one it's because you're not
acting like your ideal self right so
that's the first thing can happen and I
think that that um is sort of the easier
case the more difficult case is when
there's a fundamental tradeoff in your
values and now you're like oh wait it
turns out there's some people that the
first choice would be better for based
on their values and there's some people
that the second choice would be better
for based on vales and actually which
one is better is fully dependent on how
much I value those different things
right how much do I value this much
honesty versus this much suffering
caused to a friend there is no objective
answer it now is just on me to think
about how much I care about those two
things and that takes some of the
pressure off because it's like oh no
this is now about how much I value those
things I'm not like failing to live up
to some objective
standard that's interest do we do we
choose our values where do you think
values come from that is a great
question do we choose our values so um I
think part partly our values are
ingrained in US evolutionary or at least
the capacity to have those values for
example even like a baby doesn't like
pain right so that's you know so some of
them are are ingrained and our capacity
for the other ones are also you know
built into us we have the capacity due
to our genes um but that's not the only
thing after that we have all these life
experiences and I think those impact our
values and then I think our culture and
what we're taught impact our values I
think our values tend to be pretty
stable when you're in your like mid-20s
to 30s um they can still change a bit
but they tend to not change very much um
an example of them changing let's say
someone um well to go back you know a
religious example let's say someone is a
devout Catholic and then they have a
crisis of faith that could actually
change some of their values um or if
someone's an atheist and then they
suddenly have a experience of God that
could change some of their values but
more or less they tend to be stable and
some people ask well should I try to
change my values and I think there the
answer is no like your values are the
things you fundamentally care about why
would you change that unless in some
special cases you might have a value
that says you should change your values
but that's kind of an unusual Edge case
okay yeah it's an interesting one man I
I've had a lot of conversations over the
last few years about values and I think
what I originally had as values were
they weren't fully instrumental but they
weren't fully intrinsic either so it's
stuff like uh curiosity Adventure
self-development
Excellence they they feel they don't
feel sufficiently firm to me so I'm
going to have to go and do your uh your
tool and and see how I get up with that
strateg love to love to hear what you
think about inic values test but you
know it's interesting the things you
mentioned um because there's another
class of things that's also important
which are virtues which I would
differentiate from values so it might be
that it could be that you're thinking of
like virtues that you want to live by or
you want to reflect um but but also it
could cross over into um intrinsic
values as well so for example I have a I
have an intrinsic value of telling the
truth and that's highly connected to a
virtue of like being an honest person so
there's you know definitely a connection
yeah interesting there so there's
another layer Taylor Pearson um Tau me
about this a while ago he has a list of
operating principles that that his life
follows and I think that if I was if I
was to go complete monk mode and work uh
values virtues or ethics uh and and
operating principles I think that's a
really nice sort of Stack that takes you
from the philosophical wishy-washy to
the Strategic tactical spit and sawdust
typ stuff because what you're going to
say is um I am faced with this
particular problem regularly where my
values come into conflict with other
values and my values just come into
conflict with General discomfort in the
world I need to tell somebody something
that they don't want to hear but one of
my values is truth therefore what is the
Strat way that I go about things um when
I know that I need to tell somebody
something within the space of 24 hours
from when I have that first thought I'm
going to speak to them I'm going to do
it in a as calm of a way as possible
something like that right um like I want
to be um I don't know whether this was
classes of value but uh certainly one of
the best life hacks I've ever heard is
pay invoices immediately like pay bills
immediately pay invoices immediately
because if you get known as the sort of
person that pays immediately your
suppliers or whoever it is your
landlord's going to going to like you
more your friends are going to like you
more you you've been out for dinner and
someone asks you to PayPal them 100
bucks because they paid on their AMX
card because they hadn't hit their
spending limit for the month and uh it
takes you three weeks like just you get
known as the guy that takes three weeks
to pay somebody back for dinner just do
it straight away and it's such a great
uh operating principle for life I think
pay people that you owe them immediately
if you can it's so funny you mention
principles because actually um last year
we released a mod on figuring out your
life principles you also again Tak our
website clear.org a free module figure
out your principles and um the reason
that we developed it is because we
realize just like you're saying that
there's sort of the stack of layers to
the person to you and in that stack the
way I think about it at the bottom
there's values right it's like I think
of intrinsic values at the very bottom
like the things that you most
fundamentally value and then you build
things on top of that you build your
plans right and uh you build your goals
and so what is a good goal a good goal
from my point of view is something it's
a it's something that's challenging in
the future that helps you create the
things that you value and your plans
what's a good plan a plan a good plan is
something that helps you achieve your
goals reliably and what is a good
decision it's something that that you
know moves you directionally towards
achieving your goals and so on and then
so where does principes slot in so I've
thought about this a lot and I think
that principles are decision-making
heris sixs so if we think about a good
decision as something that moves you
towards achieving your goals a principle
is a decision-making horis rule of thumb
that helps you in practice make your
decisions more efficiently and avoiding
issues of self-control or self-doubt um
so for example I have a life principle
that when I make a mistake I should
acknowledge it and I should try to learn
from it and so if and that's really
clarifying for me because I know it's
life principle I have it written down I
review my life principles periodically
and so let's say I make a mistake and
like my brain's like well what should I
do now I don't even have to think about
it it's like oh I need to acknowledge
and then you try to learn from it right
so um so I find principles to be really
powerful and they're like just another
layer in the stack of what it what it is
to be you what about insights in other
domains of your life or the world have
you learned any of those since becoming
a fully fledged paid up Valu have you
realized other things about the way that
the world works or other people
operate oh man I mean uh so so many
things so um one thing that I've
observed as I think thought more about
valm is that there are a lot of people
that are confused about what their
values are versus other people's values
and I think this is especially common
for people that either were raised with
parents that like put a lot of pressure
on them or people that maybe tend to be
less assertive and maybe tend to like di
get dictated um their actions get
dictated by other people um but I I have
an anecdote about this which is that um
a friend of mine was feeling really
depressed and she knew it had something
to do with her boyfriend and she was
really confused and so I sat down with
her and she's like I don't get it he's
such a great guy and yet something about
the relationship is deeply unfulfilling
to me and I said okay uh let's talk
about it like tell me about how he's a
great guy and so she wrote down a list
of all his great qualities and I said
okay cool now let's write down what your
values are and so she wrote down another
list and I compared them side by side I
was like you know what's fascinating he
is a great guy but none of the things
are great about him are in line with
what you care about and then I was like
okay I have an idea here write down your
parents values so she wrote that down
and like almost perfectly matched her
boy I was like okay I think it's pretty
clear what's happened here you're dating
your the person your parents wants you
want you to date and so I think this is
a really common phenomen we actually
live for other people's values wow that
is very very interesting yeah it feels
like
um it feels like there's a relationship
here or a correlation with the
relationship we have with our future
self and the relationship that we have
with our past self right you're existing
in the now you're making goals and plans
and even thinking about your values
because there will be a future you which
is going to benefit from it that person
is going to be more well-rounded and
then you also have this continuity bias
what does it mean that I used to do that
in the past how what does it mean that I
am the same person that I was in the
past even though I feel like a different
person like you know it's been seven
years since I had that memory all of my
cells have been replaced I've ship of
thesias my way into like not even
existing as the same person anymore I've
got this continuity of Consciousness and
what's going to happen in future and
where am I going to be like it feels
like this relationship that we have
across time with our self and then the
projection of what we could become or
would want ourselves to become then
sometimes we can make deals today that
our future self has to pay or cash or
you know checks that they have to cash
in future yeah there's definitely
something going on there oh absolutely
absolutely and I think I think that's a
really powerful um idea that you just
mentioned of like making deals with your
future self it's something that that I
do uh you know like for example a really
simple way to pull that off is to say
okay you really don't want to do these
tax forms these tax forms are huge pain
in the ass but if you do them you get to
go do this special thing afterwards that
you don't normally let yourself do and
you get splurge and so like you know
that's what is that that's just a kind
of a deal with your future self and
you're like your present self's like all
right fine I'll do the tax Farms you
know um my uh I'm actually feeling a
Valu conflict right now because my cat
really wants to get out of this room get
out go get it get the cat where is she
here we go say hi
marn cats man you just can't they
they're only good for half an hour on a
podcast would be just sitting peacefully
in the background and
and fan of big fan of dogs and dogs and
cats in the background of podcast though
so I don't know why um there was this
dude Kevin Samuels he's passed away now
but he used to do um YouTube a lot and
he had this you know one of
those gyroscopic perpetual motion type
things and you'd spin it on your desk
and it would go in kind of a chaotic
pattern and he used to have this thing
on his desk and he must just give it a
kick before he started every video and I
promise you I couldn't stop looking at
this perpetual motion thing got this guy
and he's you know being expressive and
talking and explaining stuff and
sometimes even like holding things up uh
meanwhile I'm watching this this
perpetual motion machine in the
background so yeah dogs dogs and cats
have the have the same thing uh when it
comes to being a card carrying Valu what
are the hardest things about following
this philosophy where are the hair
shirts uh hiding in your in your
ideals yeah I think that one of the
hardest things is that when you really
pay attention to your values you realize
there's a bunch of ways you're not
living according to your values um or
another way to say that is if you think
about who you are and you think about
who the what the ideal version of is
like there's ways that you you don't
live up to that the way there's ways
that you're being driven by what other
people want you to do but that are not
in line with your values there's ways
that you're maybe seeking social status
when you really your values tell you you
should be more focused on something else
not to say there's anything wrong with
caring about social St to some extent
but but maybe you're not living in
accordance with your values in that way
um there may be ways that you're not
being as honest as your vales tell you
to be and so on um like here here's a
really simple example I know lots of
people who really Really Care About
Animals if they saw like an animal being
hurt in the street they would be
extremely upset and distraught and yet
they might take actions that contribute
to animals being harmed right and so you
know it's like oh wait if you're trying
to live according to your values like
what does that say about you know the
choices you make and the food you eat
and so on and and I think I use that one
example because it's a really Stark
example but I think there are a lot of
these things that come up is that
reflecting on your values also makes you
deeply aware that you're not always
living according to your values what do
do you think about the usefulness and
the role of intuition when it comes to
decision- making ah good question well
yeah this is this is something that that
I've thought about a great deal and you
know I always find it interesting when
you have two sides that yell at each
other and yet both sides have good
points but they never seem to resolve
their argument and so the two sides that
I see yelling at each other on this are
you have a lot of people who deeply in
trust their intuitions and then and they
really stand behind that they like
they're like I didn't used to trust my
intuition but I learn to trust it and
things are so much better for me now
right um and they Advocate that other
people trust it um and then if someone
says well how do I decide they're like
just go with what your guys telling you
right and then there's the other side
that are like they tend to be more like
rationalistic or or academic and they
say no our intuitions are just riddled
with biases and it's like you know
people like constantly telling you to
trust your intuition your intuition is
dumb you need to use rational analysis
and be analytic and I'm like I look at
this sheid I'm like man they both have
some great points so so I spend a bunch
of time thinking about this like what is
really true on this subject and so I
developed this thing I call the fire
framework so it's an acronym f fire and
it's about when should you trust your
gut when do you trust your intuition and
when should you second guess your
intuition and use a more rational
analytical analysis and so the the
acronym kind of tells you when you can
trust your gut um and so the first uh
letter f for fire um that stands for
fast decisions and so you know imagine
you're driving down the highway you're
going 50 miles an hour and then a car
suddenly going the opposite swerves into
your Lane right you don't have time to
use rational analysis you will die if
you use rational analysis so the first
time when you have trust your gut is
with fast decisions for obvious reasons
because our intuition is so much faster
and you could see this with things like
sports or martial arts where at first
when they're learning it they may be
doing a lot of thinking but when they're
actually really in the game um almost
all of it is automated and and going
with their going with their gut okay the
second I is irrelevant decisions so
let's say you're like oh man I you know
I'm I'm trying to order a salad but I
just don't know should I get carrots in
it or not like it is not worth 10
minutes of your life figuring out
whether you get carrots in or Salad
right you just go with your gut um or
this is a really common one you're
trying to figure out what TV show or
movie to watch and like you ever do this
with friends and you spend like an hour
trying to pick and you're like oh my God
it's like we a waste of time be better
if we flipped a coin right so no just
just uh go with your gut with it's an
irrelevant decision right okay so that's
a first two times when you should go
with your gut the third one is really
interesting and important um that's the
r for repetitious decision
so the idea here is that your intuition
is not magic it is very much not magic
but it is very smart so when is it smart
it's smart when it gets to do a thing
again and again and it gets feedback so
to think about this imagine that you're
learning archery you've got your bow and
arrow you're firing at the Target the
only problem is you're blindfolded and
you also have earplugs so you can never
find out if you hit the target or not
how long would it take you to learn to
be a good Archer I I think the answer is
infinite time forever yeah yeah yeah
forever you would never right okay um
now let's suppose okay let's suppose you
get to take the blindfold off the
earplugs off but because you have a
vision problem and a hearing problem you
only have 50% reliability of knowing
whether you hit the bll ey or not right
well now maybe you could learn a bit you
could learn a little bit but it would
take so long to learn right you might
need thousand or tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of repetitions
whereas if you get to see exactly where
you hit on the target
time after each arrow shot you're going
to learn so much faster and in fact
eventually your intuition will get so
good you don't even need to think about
it you can just pull back the bow and
fire you know perfect shot once you've
done enough and so I think this is a
good metaphor for how our intuition
Works our intuition is or essentially
our you know different parts of our mind
constantly monitor the world and
constantly see what happens and
constantly see whether the action we
took got to the result we wanted and so
if you take someone like magnet Carlson
who's played you know insanely large
number of games of Chess you can drop
him into a game of chess and he
instantly knows what to do he does not
need to do rational analysis and he will
still absolutely beat you in fact
there's a wonderful uh game he plays
against three like pretty good chess
players where he beats the crap out of
all of them and he makes his moves like
essentially instantaneously like within
seconds but the craziest part is he
doesn't get to see the board it's all
like memorized in his head during the
games and he beats them all right it's
so crazy and it's because it actually
requires no rational thought for him to
play chess however let's say he played a
new game he's never seen his life
totally different roles maybe it's not a
chessboard totally different roles he
might be a bit better than the average
but he's not going to be very good and
his intuitions are actually going to
sometimes lead him to do exactly the
wrong move right and so he's going to
he's going to uh incorrectly pattern
match this is like that situation in
chess no it's not Magnus it's got
nothing to do with chess he's going to
have to keep overriding his intuitions
because his his chess mind is going like
well it's a chess board he got chess
pieces right and so I think that a lot
of the magic of our intrution the
seeming magic is because our brain is
always watching and always learning and
it gets really good at things it gets
shockingly good in fact it gets so good
that sometimes you're like I don't even
know how I know that thing but I just
know it and it's because yeah it's been
watching your entire life and learning a
good example of this sometimes we just
get a bad Vibe about a person and like
and sometimes those are wrong you know
first pression could be wrong but I
think they're right A lot of times
surprisingly often I think when you get
a bad Vibe of meeting someone in the
first 10 minutes it's like a pretty good
chance you picked up on something
real very interesting is that the that's
R that's repetitive that's R so we do
the last one evolutionary decisions and
so this e the E for evolutionary
decisions the idea here is that well we
were created by Evolution right that's
that's where we came from and if you
look at an animal like a cat or a snake
you notice they have a bunch of
reactions that they seem to know how to
do and they didn't seem to learn it from
their parents right well we too are
animals of A Sort right um and so there
are some things we know how to do our
gut knows how to do them that uh we
never had to learn um and so an example
of this if a SP puts a steak in front of
you and it smells rotten don't eat it
right like that is an evolutionary
intuition that you have um if you hear
suddenly an extremely loud noise you
will probably jump away before you even
realized it and that is probably a
really good decision because the chance
that a bunch of like you know gold is
about to land your hands is much lower
than the chance that you're something
really bad is about to happen to you
right so that intuition that a really
loud noise means something dangerous is
occurring is a pretty good intuition
it's not always right but it's a good
intuition so so there a whole bunch of
these evolutionary ones but so so that's
the idea the fire framework that these
four situations fast decisions relevant
decisions repetitious decisions and
evolutionary decisions when you can
trust your gut and outside of that is
when rational analysis tends to lead to
better outcomes got you have you got any
strategies for how people can integrate
intuition and subconscious into their
more reflective rational decision-making
I think that's probably a lot of what
people want you know I I understand I
probably need to think about this a
little bit but I feel like I'm maybe
applying more cerebral horsepower to
this than I need to and it's causing me
to H it's causing me discomfort uh I'm
I'm sort of weighed down with all of the
different thought structures about this
thing I kind of just want to think about
it a bit then feel it and then go yeah
it's a great question because okay we
say all right well there are certain
times when you want to do reflective
decision- making analytical decision-
making but like how do you do that right
and I think a common failure mode is
ignoring your intuition and so where
there's there's a really big distinction
between letting your analysis run the
show and ignoring your intuition there's
not the same thing so let's think of an
example um imagine that you meet someone
and you have a bad reaction to them like
in a few minutes of meeting them right
and then you're thinking about it later
and um now your your intuition there has
some real information important
information
and some people they'll think rationally
and they'll be like well but they didn't
really do anything wrong and if I like
replay the conversation in my head there
wasn't any specific thing they said that
like indicated they were a bad person or
whatever but to ignore your intuition
there is a dumb idea at the same time to
let it completely determine your view of
this person if you go around badmouthing
this person now that's probably not
warranted either and so it's like the
the right way to do reflection is to
incorporate the intuition and learn from
it what you can use as a source of
information but not it necessarily compl
run the show right um and so so how do
you do that well part of it is that you
can try to hone in on what your
intuition is picking up on right and I
find thought experiments can be really
useful with this um so you could say for
example let's say this person rubbed you
the wrong way you could think to
yourself H well was it the first part of
the conversation like if I just had the
first part of the conversation would I
have had a negative vibe you're like no
no no actually that would have been okay
um you know was it something about like
their facial expression you know like
let's say that they had been smiling do
you think I would have pressed it
differently and you can kind of try to
like you know zoom in on like what your
intuition is picking up on it's a little
bit like if you're studying like what a
neural net is doing it's like how did
your intuition is kind of like a neural
net it's like this giant Network that's
doing these incredibly complex
operations but they're kind of hidden
and then later you know AI researchers
are like well what on Earth was this
neurl net picking up on how did it
decide what's a dog and what's a cat and
they'll try to like back that out and
they'll try to say Well it seem to be
honing in on these parts of the image
and so maybe it's picking up on whiskers
or you know
yeah it's interesting to think about how
our intuition and our sort of cognition
battle against each other and after a
while I've certainly found this with
myself I can end up talking myself out
of or into pretty much any sensation or
emotion and then after a while you don't
even have a relationship with your
intuition anymore you have a
relationship with the story that you
told yourself about what your intuition
meant which is now taking it from the
realm of intuition into the realm of
cognition and now you're trying to think
what does it mean that I'm the sort of
person that thinks that I'm the sort of
person that takes their intuition into
the realm of cognition uh yeah that that
spiral is uh
useless yeah it it's really tricky I
think a lot of people struggle with this
I um I had a friend who um had some
really traumatic things happen to her
and she found that it became
increasingly difficult to Hon in on her
intuition and to trust it and I think
what happens sometimes is your tissue
intuition can kind of get noisy like
let's say you have traumatic event and
you're feeling fear a lot of the time
maybe you're feeling fear all the time
and then suddenly it's like well okay
I'm afraid does that mean something
bad's about to happen or is it just like
my you know hyperactive system is all
fired up right and then you can learn
and then it with that you can start to
learn to not trust your intuition right
which is a which is also really bad it's
like you have these two incredibly
powerful tools you've got your your
power of analysis and reasoning and
you've got your intuition and some
people are saying no just leave one tool
in the tool box you're like are you
crazy why would you ever do that You'
got these two really powerful tools
learn to be a master of both of them
right yeah you say uh we we've spoke
offline about the importance of becoming
wise it's something that you that you
care about a lot as well why do you
think it's so important and what's your
definition of
wisdom ah yes well I thought this was
really relevant just because of you know
the name of your podcast I actually
wanted to ask you like so you got a
podcast it's called modern wisdom what
is what is wisdom to you like why why
did you call it that uh the reason I
called it that was I wanted to try and
have something that felt sufficiently
connected
to the accumulated human knowledge bank
that I was I wanted to be dipping into
but that it was purposefully built for
the mismatched contemporary environment
that we find ourselves in right that I
got toward the end of my 20s and I
didn't really understand myself or how
the world worked or how I was supposed
to behave and and what my values should
be and and what ethics were and I I I
felt like I should know these things
that it wasn't unknown knowledge I
wasn't asking questions for which there
were no answers that were known it was
just that I needed to be shown the way
and then importantly the Tactical SL
applied element of it uh is okay and
what does this mean to take some you
know Aristotelian ethic and then try and
apply it to a world for which it wasn't
originally written um you know I think a
lot of people know things but when it
comes to understanding their application
it's it's rough like people get stuck
you know they've got the quote written
on their whiteboard or or they've it's
their background of their phone screen
saver But ultimately like the spit and
sest of whether or not this thing
happens is its applicability it's
strategically tactically can I actually
apply this thing uh when it comes to
wisdom I
think your actions having the
consequences that you intended them to
have is probably not far off for me um
like intention action and outcome being
aligned feels like something that's
right but there's one bit that's missing
there which is what did you intend to
intend there's like one step above high
level yeah there's one more step that
I've missed out of that you would have
thought after 700 episodes of a show
called modern wisdom that I would have
some beautiful succinct definition of it
and I did for a while but I actually
found that having some
cookie cutter maybe it was written by me
it was probably some Frankenstein's
monster bastardized from like a bunch of
different people I actually found that
that was a bit constricting uh
because I was I had a readymade answer
when people ask me this question I had a
readymade answer that I churned out that
didn't require me to assess do I still
believe that this is true and uh I had a
conversation with Sam ens this dude who
spent a lot of time creating internet
content and he actually stopped doing
all of his content for the same reason
he found that he was making
proclamations on his YouTube videos and
on his podcasts that his real world self
felt the obligation to live up to so he
was saying things in the virtual world
that him in the real world then felt the
need to actually go out and do and then
he was like being held hostage by
statements that he'd made and he had
this very sort of strange
Persona personality relationship going
on and and and he felt ATT tension with
that so just generally as a rule I think
um it's nice to have it's kind of like
the the to bring It full circle it's
kind of like the Myers Briggs of of
personal development like it's nice to
have a succinct simple way somebody asks
you in a in an elevator uh like I'm anj
or whatever but the actual deeper
version of this is to have the sliding
scale which is more like big five it's
like okay what do I actually think about
this used to have this idea it was about
action and intention and and outcome
kind of being the same but you know I've
got this other bit that I've added in
that it doesn't feel like it's a part of
it so I think that's I think just as a
Meta Meta Meta rule I think that's
really important to continually assess
the um like commonplace book answers
that you have for questions that you
regularly end up talking about um and
and assess those pretty frequently uh
and periodize it like give yourself an
answer sit back rely on that for a
little while then fight with some other
definitions or some other terms that
you're looking at and then and then come
back in but yeah that's my that's my
idea around wisdom and the name and and
the definition oh I I really like that I
think you captured a lot of the critical
elements and what I find really
fascinating about wisdom is it seems
like one of the most important things to
to become wise and yet it's very hard to
come up with a definition that people
will agree with and there's so many
different definitions floating around
and so that intrigued me and so I
started doing analysis of different
definitions
and I ended up coming with a up with a
bunch of different definitions each
inspired sort of by different thinkers
or different ways of looking at the
problem um so I'll just mention three of
them that uh the first the first is this
idea of wisdom as self-consistency and
this one was inspired by the work of
Justin chevlin and um Elliot mckernan
and so the idea here is that to be wise
is to have a consistency between the key
elements of yourself so consistency
between your values your beliefs and
your actions and so an example would be
imagine that you value being honest but
you're being dishonest right well well
immediately that's a that's a your
values are not align with your actions
right so you're not being consistent
you're not being wise um or imagine that
you believe you should You' be best if
you became a doctor but you're actually
pursuing being a lawyer right so there
that is actually a conflict again
between your beliefs this time and your
actions and so that those three pieces
all being in alignment is wisdom so
that's kind of the the first idea any
reaction to that one that feels that
feels not too dissimilar to me values
beliefs actions as uh like intention
action outcome um I suppose the one
thing that's missing there would be
would be the outcome and I think that
that's a very important part because um
what you want from any
wisdom philosophy is to be able to
accurately predict the impact of the
things that you're going to do I think
that's super super important and I think
that uh an awful lot of wisdom comes
down to being able to achieve the ends
that you meant to and to know the ends
that you mean to get
to yeah that's a great point and
actually that's really tied into the
second definition of wisdom which I
which I I call wisdom as causal control
and um this is inspired by work of Veri
and Ferraro although guy johi being on
the podcast he's a modern wisdom alumni
oh nice I don't know if he would agree
with this but but it's inspired by his
work so um it's this idea that wisdom is
about both the ability and the
propensity to consider the complex
situation that you're in and then
through your understanding of yourself
the world and other people produce what
are on average beneficial outcomes right
so there's a swirl of like complexity
but you kind of sift through that and
you say ah if you take this action in
this complex situation on average that
will lead to good outcomes and it has to
be on average because the world's
probabilistic right there's no way for
example at poker to win every time the
best you can do is win on average and so
much of life is like that so yeah that
sort of to me that sort of captures
second piece that you were actually
referring to 100% wisdom is knowledge
multiplied by goodness what's that ah
yeah so this is sort of sometimes you'll
hear people say things like wisdom is
you know knowledge times altruism or
knowledge times goodness right and so I
thought about that a bunch and I was
like okay there maybe is something to
that and so first of all I think we can
say that like knowledge is an element of
wisdom right I think most people would
say if you you know if you don't have
any knowledge like it's hard to be wise
right at the same time being good seems
to be an element of wisdom right if you
are totally evil or you're totally self-
serving it seems be strange to call you
wise and so we can say Okay wisdom seems
to be related to these two things
knowledge and goodness right but how is
it related to those two things is it
more like a sum of those two things well
if it were some of those two things then
you could still get a high wisdom score
by being really knowledgeable if even if
you were Super Evil and that doesn't
seem right you're using all your knowled
just to you know Serve Yourself or
something uh or you could get a really
good wisdom score score by being really
good person but knowing nothing being
completely ignorant that doesn't seem
right either so it seems like it's more
like a product like multiplying
knowledge and goodness together and the
reason is because zero times anything is
zero right so if you're zero knowledge
no matter how good you are you still get
a zero wisdom and even if you're not 0.9
you're less knowledgeable your your
wisdom is less than your knowledge if
you're bad or if you're not as as you
could be ex exactly so they multiply
together and so you actually need both
and then and they kind of like
complement each other and so that's
that's this third idea kind of an
intuitive notion of wisdom that I like
it's interesting that there's this sort
of
benevolence um to wisdom right it's
atically from first principles leaves
the world in a better place than it was
when it found it that there is I think
that the goodness part uh is is pretty
important um maybe there's an element of
assumption that sufficient understanding
of intention and action uh would fold
goodness in like atically like is
something that should be a part of any
sufficiently knowledgeable system they
should also arrive at
goodness and although I'm sure that
there's some philosophical theory that
literally would say that that may be the
way that it works functionally I don't
think it is like you have to design this
for the idiot Apes that are going to use
it and I think that goodness is
sufficiently important that it Bears
adding it in as another factor of your
uh the wisdom equation uh all right
we've I just want to say that's that's
such an interesting point and this is
something I actually often debate with
my guest on the clear Thinking podcast
where they'll make an argument that like
goodness is this fundamental force in
the universe or like is an objective
thing and I'm like no no no it's like
about your own values and so I think
there's two ways to Arise at this
goodness piece one is to say you know
objectively like if you're sufficiently
intelligent you'll figure out that being
good is like is objectively right and
but the other way to get it which is
more the way I take is like actually if
reflect on your values almost everyone
cares about being good in different ways
whether it's being honest or reducing
suffering or you know helping your your
loved ones and so goodness comes about
because our value almost all of us have
values that involve goodness interesting
so do you
think on average that most of the people
who end up doing evil things are doing
that because of an instrumental
value ah that is such a good question
there are a bunch of different types of
evil um so one type of evil is what I
call call philosophical disorder um a
philosophical disorder is when you
deeply believe something important that
is both false and harmful to believe and
so take an example of someone who joins
a cult and they become convinced by the
cult leader that they should go blow up
a building right that is someone doing
evil from a philosophical disorder they
have a false harmful belief that they're
executing but that person might be like
really kind and altruistic they might
think they're saving the world right
that is an extremely different type of
evil than someone who is evil because
they only care about their own interests
they literally are completely
indifferent to the interests of all
other people other than themselves um
and while there are some people like
that there are some people that only
care about their own interest completely
indifferent to the interests of anyone
else of themselves they're actually
extremely rare extremely rare and I
think actually most evil in the world is
not caused by that kind of person
fascinatingly enough even though you
might you might think that it that would
be yeah uh my friend ginda really smart
guy from the UK has a bunch of different
things about evil he says uh the world's
few evil people cannot enact their plans
without the world's many stupid ones
therefore stupidity is a far greater
threat than evilness and I think that in
some regards that's quite true there's a
another insight about how the world has
very few original thinkers and most
people end up being kind of marionett by
whatever their favorite influencer does
so you get this kind of mimetic echo
Cascade thing going on um but yeah I
would agree you know if you look at most
of the super super evil people from
history if you actually look at what
they were trying to do they were driven
by what they saw as a benevolent goal
the uh externalities of the path that
they took to achieve that goal ended up
in massive amounts of suffering and and
reprehensible Behavior
but I don't know I don't know how many
people live on this Earth who are like
like from first principles oh they're
evil like intrinsically they value
harming people and causing suff
suffering and discomfort and pain and
all this sort of stuff it's mostly I am
on a righteous path I have it's the like
Thanos right it's like all roads lead
back to Thanos like I have an outcome I
believe is is worthwhile but the route
to get there is one that many other the
people would say is evil well you know
it's it's fascinating so we ran this
study on intrinsic values and we had
people we we taught people what they
were and then we had them submit what
they thought there were we got 3,000
submissions we looked through them we
duplicated them we categorized them I
don't think there was a single person in
there that like had an intrinsic value
of harming other people right so I'm not
saying it's it's literally impossible
there might be some people out there
that like actually their values are
harming others but I think actually in
practice the most evil fundamentally
evil people it's just that they don't
have intrinsic values of helping others
or you know you know but they're I I
think even them they they like they
don't have an intrinsic value of harming
others which you know honestly
thankfully right like think about how
bad that would be and it's fascinating
because if you watch cartoons or movies
about
evil it's almost always the case that
they actually have a seem to have a
value of harm which is bizarre like why
do we cook up these fictional worlds
that have nothing to do with reality
well it's because it simplifies it down
right um that being said I was thinking
about Lion King You Know The Lion King
the Mufasa and Scar the reason that scar
is is such a a deck is he wants the
control of Pride Rock right he wants to
take that but that being said there's
you know there's many
all of the um evil guys throughout most
of the Avengers except for Thanos
actually who makes for like an interest
he's another interesting case right like
he's got this what he sees is a
benevolent goal but isn't in the end but
yeah so many of the cartoon movie Super
Villains just have oh he's just the bad
guy right um they fundamentally want to
C home yeah yeah one of my friends is
doing this really interesting study at
the moment to do with um physical
attractiveness and uh perceived goodness
so like the goodness of a person and um
if you look at you know many stories
popular culture uh the bad person has
some form of physical disfigurement
right it's like a a physical
manifestation of this malignant internal
uh state or philosophy and um yeah he's
going to he's going to run this this
facial analysis to like Eve Psych uh
based facial analysis study which I
think will be really
interesting that's really interesting I
hope he finds that there's no
correlation between people something
tells me that it's not going to happen
something tells me we're going to be an
uncomfortable realization I feel like
one of the a form of prejudice that is
very accepted in society and I think
should be much less accepted is people
basically on unattracted people
like I just think that's you know nobody
chooses to have you know you think about
how arbitrary the little bumps in our
faces are to determine whether we're
good-looking versus average
versus even with that it's it's not just
the on the people who are not
good-looking there is the even if you
don't actively on the person that
isn't good-look by giving benefits to
the person that is good-looking it is
like by a mission rather than commission
still damaging the person that isn't and
much as that degree of egalitarianism in
the world would be maybe useful I think
it is we're way too evolutionarily kind
of lock in for that all right we've got
three more uh wisdom as a virtue what's
that ah wisdom as virtue so this is the
idea that being wise is about
demonstrating these certain virtues you
know the virtue of Courage the virtue of
honesty the virtue of kindness and so I
think this is like kind of a very
traditional view of wisdom it's like
about who you are as a person what you
manifest rather than sort of a more
intellectual view of
wisdom yeah what do you think about this
yeah this is this is like the medieval
uh hero story this is like Shrek Shrek
wisdom right like I'm going to do the
thing um yeah I'm looking at some of the
things here factual knowledge self-
knowledge and understanding firsthand
experience Common Sense compassion
altruism impartiality non-attachment
objectivity epistemic humility courage
yeah the this is this is definitely like
the tradcon side of wisdom I wonder
whether this would be folded into the
goodness uh part of your wisdom equation
maybe not you know like is impartiality
non-attachment courage like is courage a
part of goodness it's probably not you
would say that most people who are
courageous are good but not all people
that are good are courageous so yeah I
think um I think this is probably this
is probably useful and you do need to
pay a little bit of lip service to the
um like
vestigal wisdom uh world you know like
uh there's a nod to kind kind of what it
what it was and and maybe traditionally
what it would have been considered right
I think that's right and you can also
think of it as a bit of a recipe because
if you take this really abstract
definition of like you know looking at
all the complex causes and picking out
the action to take like okay well how
the hell do you do that it's like well
maybe you become the kind of person that
is courageous so that you can take the
right action whereas other people won't
take the right action and you become the
kind of person that's uh you know
unbiased or fair so that you can like
evaluate things you know even hand and
so on so it's a little bit of like how
who do you become in order to be able to
do that um which I think can be a useful
way of thinking about things awesome
okay wisdom as
search yeah so I think this one of the
more abstract ones um so it's basically
about exploring the essential truths
about life the cause and effect of
things and then basically applying these
insights to both theoretical and real
life situations and so it's like think
of it as like um uh you're like thinking
about the big questions the important
questions you're not focused on the you
know unimportant things you're focused
on the big things and then you search to
actually find those answers and then
once you get those answers you use them
you apply them as tools and so I think
the emphasis of this definition of
wisdom is it's really more of like
wisdom as a process that you go through
rather than like a thing that you
do right wisdom is a process rather than
it's a thing that you do well right so
it's not like oh you have a difficult
decision and now you suddenly act wise
it's no no it's like wisdom is like the
fact that You' your whole life pursuing
the answers to the big things and then
like you know figuring out how to
incorporate them right yeah yeah it it
it almost sort of speaks to the the
compounding effect of wisdom this maybe
plays into the the Elder Druid style
person sat around the campfire bestowing
his stories on the youth so to speak
that it's this accumulated thing that
you continue to to pick up throughout
your life exactly exactly by the way I
you know I think it says something about
your audience that you want me to go
through all these definitions cuz I was
like there's no way we're going to get
through more than three of these you do
not know this audience they're like tell
me what if if we stopped now if we
stopped now and only did five of the six
it would be there would be a barrage of
very very bad comments so the final one
wisdom as perspective okay so this is
about the idea of viewing things from
multiple Vantage points I don't know if
you've ever like how to guest talk about
like Spiral Dynamics or this kind of
idea no I really want to get into it do
you know anyone that's like super super
good at communicating spiral Dynamics uh
well I'm happy to tell you my take on it
but I don't know no I don't know I don't
know who the the best expert to talk on
it um this is uh what's his face
transcend and include right I don't I
don't know that that name doesn't ring a
bell there actually a bunch of people
who've written in different ways about
these related Concepts yeah okay
interesting is it not Ken Wilbur is Ken
Wilbur like a big part that is yeah he's
one of the like Founders that it
connects to good okay anyway so wisdom
is perspective spiral Dynamics yeah yeah
yeah so there's this idea in spiral
dynamics of sort of these uh the S call
them different colors of like ways of
seeing the world that like the way of
seeing the world when you're like alone
self trying to survive versus in a small
tribe and so on and and as you get near
the top I think it's often it's like the
second to last stage there's this stage
where you see all the stages below you
see all the other ways of looking at the
world that have come before whether
you're in a tribe or a big civilization
or an individual alone in the woods and
then you incorporate all of them in your
worldview and you kind of see the
strengths and the weakness of each of
them so this is wisdom as perspective
it's like you you're able to take on
every you know lens and kind of
triangulate between all of them and I
think that's a you know it's an
interesting it's interesting take it's
definitely something that I aspire to
try to do um I don't know they captures
all of wisdom but I think it captures
sort of an interesting piece of
it yeah what would what would wisdom be
like if you didn't have wisdom's
perspective as one of
the uh arms of this six-legged octopus
yeah I think that I think you know the
the danger there is that like you're
stuck in one perspective right like
maybe it's a wise perspective but then
you can't step outside of it right
whereas like wisdom as perspective is
like you could see the strengths of
weaknesses of every way of looking at
this problem and then you can balance
them and you can like take the good bits
and and you can switch between them and
um yeah it's uh it D it does not
surprise me that um people who want to
try and be wise in life have a a
nightmare I mean look at the incredibly
High hurdles that you've just decided to
Define for how everybody needs to you
know okay you want to be wise well here
is this Gauntlet of hell that
you need to go through um but I one of
the like tactical ways to do this
certainly from my life like a lot of the
things that you go through that are to
me intrinsically rewarding um you know
knowledge uh causal control
self-consistency uh when I haven't had
these things in my life have been some
of the times that I've felt the worst
about myself you know when I haven't
felt like I've been able to enact change
when I've had an external locus of
control when I'm not self-consistent my
actions and my intentions and my beliefs
and my values and then my outcomes also
they're all over the place uh like my
knowledge when I'm not increasing my
knowledge I'm not learning more if I
even increase my knowledge but use it in
a manipulative way I learn neural
linguistic programming but do it to like
distract someone while I steal a bar of
chocolate or something like that that
wouldn't feel particularly good to me uh
and then yeah wisdom is a virtue as well
I've really enjoyed this sort of
accumulation cumulative effect uh over
time so I
think wisdom just as a word presuming
that people have the right set of
definitions of it is something that's
probably pretty easy to actually
encourage yourself to chase down because
the process at each single step of the
way makes you feel pretty good about
yourself it makes your life better and
it makes the world around you better too
it's like pretty a universal Panacea for
most problems yeah I think it's
definitely gratifying to pursue these so
it doesn't have to be grueling of course
you're never going to achieve these
things right it's impossibility these
are these are ideals to to Aspire to and
if you do well on even one of these
definitions I think you're doing great
so I think tring s six definition seems
yeah that's a lot hell yeah Spencer
Greenberg ladies and gentlemen Spencer
I'm so glad that we got introduced man
we got linked up by mutual friend
William maskill and uh he said I know
that you guys are going to get on well
super super impressed and your website
is is awesome there's tons and tons of
resources on there so where should
people go they want to keep up to date
with all the things that you're doing oh
thank you so much for having me on I'm
really really grateful this was such a
fun conversation um so if you want to
hear more from me I have a podcast
called the clear Thinking podcast um we
also have a website clear.org we have
over 70 completely free tools you can
use that we offer as a public service
from measuring your intrinsic values to
helping you form healthy habits with
their daily ritual tool and you know 68
others so we would love for you to check
it out hell yeah Spencer I appreciate
you thank you man if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe